(pleasant music)
- I'm Margaret Chowning.
I am a historian and I'm also the chair
of the Moses Lectureship Committee.
In 1937, University of California
President Robert Gordon Sproul
and the UC Board of Regions established
the Bernard Moses Memorial Lectureship
in the Social Sciences.
The lectureship honors the
memory of the late Bernard Moses,
a professor of history
and political science
at the University of California
from 1875 to 1911 and
an Emeritus professor
from 1911 until his death in 1930.
Professor Moses earned
a worldwide reputation
for his contributions to understanding
the problems of the
Latin American Republics
and as a pioneer scholar.
Professor Moses served as a
member of the United States
Philippine Commission from 1900 to 1904.
Past lecturers have
included Herma Hill Kay,
Nicholas Riasanovsky, George Lakoff,
Kenneth Stampp, Carolyn
Merchant, Jean Lave,
Emmanuel Saez, Yuri Slezkine,
Aihwa Ong, and Mary Ann Mason.
And now I'd like to say a few words
about our speaker today, Ann Swidler.
Professor Swidler is a
distinguished sociologist
whose work is highly
influential in how scholars
think about culture, religion
and social institutions.
She's often cited for
her now classic article,
Culture In Action, published in 1986,
in which she presents
the idea that culture
shapes a toolkit of
styles, skills and habits
which in turn shape individual's
strategies of action.
Swidler's interest in
culture and institutions
led to the study of how
societies in sub-Saharan Africa
responded to the AIDS pandemic.
Her recent work analyzes
global and local responses
to this epidemic in Africa looking at how
the massive international AIDS effort
interacts with existing African cultural
and institutional patterns.
Her newest book, with Susan Cotts Watkins,
is A Fraught Embrace:
The Romance and Reality
of AIDS Altruism in Africa,
forthcoming from Princeton
University Press.
Professor Swidler earned
her masters and doctorate
in sociology at UC Berkeley
and her undergraduate degree
cum laude from Harvard University.
A professor in the Department
of Sociology since 1987,
she also taught on the sociology faculty
at Harvard and at Stanford.
Additionally, she has
been a Guggenheim fellow,
French-American Foundation
Professor of American Civilization,
fellow of the Successful Societies Program
of the Canadian Institute
for Advanced Research,
visiting scholar at The
Russell Sage Foundation
and fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences.
Ann Swidler's lecture first inquires
as to what makes institutions good
before questioning how such institutions
might be achieved given
our current political,
social, and economic
conditions, yikes (chuckles).
Drawing on several studies of politics
across national contexts,
including her studies
of chieftaincy in sub-Saharan Africa,
Swidler's lecture will highlight critical
institutional features that most analysts
of political institutions neglect.
Long temporal horizons, shared cultural
and ritual forms, systems
of status aggregation,
narrative power and elite consolidation.
Please join me in welcoming
Professor Ann Swidler.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you very much.
This is a tremendous honor
and I'm delighted to be here.
Giving this lecture got a lot harder,
but the ideas it grapples with
are even more important
after November 8th.
Perhaps the relevant caution
is that in our reaction
to the election, further weakening of
American institutions is the wrong answer.
This was a traumatic
election in which our own
political institutions seemed
continuously under assault.
Aware of the longer-term fraying of many
of the institutional practices
we may have taken for granted
as a solid framework for our lives
it is even more necessary to think about
whether we can create good institutions.
I want to begin by discussing
the words of my title, one by one.
I'll start with we.
I am thinking of we in two potentially
very different senses.
One is the we I have been
studying in sub-Saharan Africa.
We, not necessarily all of you,
of the developed West, as
we look around the world
and attempt, usually unsuccessfully
to build or reconstruct state
or community institutions
in places as diverse as formerly war-torn
Liberia and Sierra Leone, or more urgently
Afghanistan, Somalia, Libya and other
failed or near-failing states
or most notoriously as
we failed spectacularly
to help build or rebuild a state in Iraq
after the 2003 invasion that
overthrew Saddam Hussein.
Colin Powell is said to
have warned George W. Bush.
Pottery Barn rules, you
break it, it's yours.
But that catastrophe revealed
more than Bush's fecklessness.
We have lots of ideas,
some only fantasies,
about how to dismantle power,
suspicion of government, a
distrust of power and of elites,
run deep in American political culture.
But just think how bare
our cupboard of ideas
was when we tried to rebuild
after dismantling the Iraqi government.
We are inept in nation building even when
we attempt to create more egalitarian,
democratic, participatory
or empowering institutions.
It is easy to condemn
the Bush administration
for giving no thought
to post-invasion Iraqi
law and order, for purging
Sunnis from the military
and the civil service and so on.
But what I find even more frightening
about the failed
post-invasion reconstruction
is that the experts we sent
to do the nation building
were a small group with expertise
in guess what, writing constitutions.
That is where our expertise
and institution building
more or less begins and ends.
An idea that fits with our
own political narrative
but has little applicability elsewhere.
I also mean we in another and
perhaps more urgent sense.
We ourselves as we now
try to protect, sustain,
adapt or rebuild the institutions
upon which we depend.
Here we may think of
institutions as precious
and apparently fragile
as the university itself,
local community institutions,
or institutions like marriage and family,
or the regulatory institutions
that structure our economy.
We lack both theory and research about how
to preserve the institutional legacies
that hold our social life together
while adapting to changing circumstances
for reworking institutions so that
they more fully embody our ideals.
Now the word institutions.
The term institutions long the provenance
of anthropologists and sociologists
has more recently become the hot topic
in political science
and economics as well.
The reasons for this
ascendance are relatively
straightforward and come
from several directions.
As economists and political
scientists explore
the limits of rational choice
theories of human behavior
they faced Hobbes's
question, if people pursue
their self-interests
what creates and enforces
the rules that govern that competition?
These are the quote "non-contractual
elements of contract
"essential to any contract
the rules that determine
"a contract's validity and the authority
"that enforces its
provisions can't be created
"by the contracting parties themselves."
So scholars ask where do the rules
and the authority to
enforce the rules come from?
The current preoccupation
with institutions
also comes from more pressing concerns.
After the breakup of the Soviet Union
it seemed evident that challenging power
needed to be complemented by concern
with governance and I
remembered this moment
when the Berkeley edited
journal Representations
changed its editorial
statement to acknowledge
that criticizing power
was not the only task
that intellectuals needed
to pay attention to.
So with the dangers of
chaos, ethnic fragmentation,
as in the Balkans in civil war
new institutions also seem vital to meet
the challenges of the global social order
in which we have vast
biological, social and economic
interdependencies without
an organizational capacity
to manage that interdependence,
and that is certainly the
challenge that the next generation
should we have a next
generation will face.
So what are institutions?
The minimal definition of an institution
is a set of rules and the
ability to enforce them.
Or slightly expanded, a
pattern of expected action
of individuals or groups
enforced by social sanctions
both positive and negative.
An institution may be as
informal as the custom
of shaking hands in a social situation,
where the refusal to respond
to an outstretched hand
might cause embarrassment and
some need for an explanation.
Or institutions may be
formal sets of complex rules
that organize entire
domains of social life
like the corporation, the
university, the family, the state.
It is also evident that
however external and objective
institutions may feel at any given moment
government, the university,
marriage and the market
are also subject to constant renegotiation
of their defining features, their rules,
and their actual rewards and sanctions.
So the paradox of institutions
and I think this is something none of us
have ever fully wrapped
our heads around is that
on the one hand institutions stand as
obdurate, enduring, that's
part of what the word
institutionalized implies,
enduring structures
that are in some sense out there
and we orient ourselves to them,
and yet we are also
constantly modifying them.
And so one of the questions
is what are the limits?
In what ways do institutions sometimes
appear unmodifiable and at other times
appear utterly fragile and easy to,
relatively easy to change.
So to these features a set of relatively
stable rules and the associated
rewards and sanctions
that enforce these rules I would add
a third crucial feature
and for those of you
who know I'm thinking very
strongly here of Philip Selznick
and his, the sociological
tradition from which he came.
The implicit or explicit
purposes these forms serve
purposes are integral to institutions
so that we really cannot understand
how they operate
concretely without thinking
about the purposes that justify them.
For example, if the purpose of a handshake
is to greet someone while
suggesting friendly intentions
one can decline a handshake with a smile
and an apology for having one's hands full
substituting the intention
for the actual action.
As we have redefined formal
institutions like marriage
a sense of their larger purposes has also
been essential to the debate,
so we modified the formal structures
of our institutions in light of
what we understand their purposes to be.
Purposes play a more central role
than many scholars recognize
in how institutions work.
So the university is an institution
a set of recognized
structures, rules and purposes
that would allow us
for example to know how
to start a new university
that is it's something
like a recipe or a model
that's out there even
when it's not being used and should we
decide to initiate a
new university probably
a foolish venture at this
moment in history but anyway
we would assemble professors, students,
labs, classrooms and so forth.
But even with all these
ingredients assembled
we would deny the term university
to what is only a profit
making organization
without an educational mission,
although this is certainly the boundary
that Trump University
for example has tested.
We say that isn't a real university
no matter what its name is and that's,
I just want you to
recognize that your ability
to say that isn't a real X is precisely
a measure of the reality of the
existence of an institution.
If that gap can't exist then
you don't have an institution.
There is a tension between
an institutionalized form
and it's actual instantiation
at any given moment or in any given form.
My co-authors and I
describe this in our book,
The Good Society, using
the example of baseball.
And I quote us, "Baseball
with its purposes,
"codes and standards, is a
collective moral enterprise.
"An institution in the full sense
"and many Americans care deeply about it.
"As an institution baseball
is more than the actual
"players and organizations
who play the game
"during any given season.
"This was beautifully expressed in 1989
"when the former President of Yale,
"late Baseball Commissioner
A. Bartlett Giamatti
"announced his decision to
ban Pete Rose from Baseball
"for having gambled on the sport,
"and Giamatti wrote, 'I
believe that baseball
'is an important, enduring
American institution.
'It must assert and aspire
to the highest of principals
'of integrity, of
professionalism, of performance,
'of fair play within its rules.
'It will come as no surprise
that like any institution
'composed of human beings this institution
'will not always fulfill
its highest aspirations.
'I know of no earthly
institution that does.
'But this one because it is so much a part
'of our history as a
people and because it has
'such a purchase on our national soul
'has an obligation to the
people for whom it is played,
'to its fans and its well-wishers,
'to strive for excellence in all things
'and to promote the highest ideals.'
"We make the same distinction when we say
"that a decision by our
university was unworthy of it
"or betrayed its mission,
or when we make a similar
"judgment about whether
members of a real family
"would treat each other in certain ways,
"or whether a real friend
would betray a confidence.
"Thus institutional forms
are defined by purposes
"that transcend their
concrete limitations."
Okay why do purposes matter?
Institutionally defined purposes matter
not only when they sound
moral and high-minded.
Such purposes allow those
working in actual organizations
to coordinate their activities
as when a corporation
sees its purposes profit,
or when a university
defines itself as devoted
to scholarship or learning.
To use an example with which
many of us are familiar
while we may be cynical about whether
teaching and scholarly
action, excellence sorry,
actually guide every decision
we make in the university.
Without a sense of such
purposes how could we decide
what undergraduates to admit,
what graduate students
should receive fellowships,
which faculty to hire or promote,
and the hundreds of other
decisions we make daily
about grading, writing
letters of recommendation,
designing courses and
hundreds of other tasks
if we did not have the
discourse available to us?
Perhaps a discourse with
multiple visions and contention
about the fundamental
purposes of the university.
Those purposes link institutional
models and their ideals
to the nitty-gritty struggles
of daily organizational life.
Now the word good.
Then what are good institutions?
I have a very simple
definition of good institutions
although in practice it's quite difficult
to measure and evaluate institutions
along a single dimension.
Good institutions for
my purposes are those
that create and maintain
collective goods, ah ha.
Goods, the good maintain goods, all right.
What I mean by collective
goods, and this overlaps
with what economists mean by public goods,
are peace and security,
infrastructure such as
roads and clean water,
and services such as
public health, education,
economic opportunity,
justice and the rule of law
and at national and global
levels effective responses
to such matters as climate
change, global health and peace.
Other conceptions of what
makes good institutions
like (mumbles) definition
of justice is the capacities
that nurture human freedom,
or ideas of democracy
and equality are important
ideals but building them
into the definition of good
institutions blinkers us I think
since most institutions
throughout most of human history
did not meet our particularly
modern conceptions of good.
Finally, the word create.
Usually we don't imagine
creating institutions
but rather inheriting them
from the distant past.
Indeed while there are moments of
radical institutional innovation.
The Constitutional Congress
of the United States,
the formation of the League of Nations,
or the United Nations, or the
International Criminal Court.
We usually inherit institutions
and modify them only gradually.
Indeed the conundrum we
face at the current moment
is that institutions
seem so easy to destroy
but very hard to rebuild.
Institutions depend on the
past in two fundamental ways,
one is that over time institutional
endowments accumulate.
This can be true in the
literal sense as when
a university accumulates a
large financial endowment,
but also in a larger cultural sense
when the loyalties and
commitments of an organization's
members or its prestige or reputation
what we would now cynically call its brand
have accumulated in many small increments
over a long period of time.
The ability of a government
to exercise authority,
of a tax system to collect taxes,
or for example the Supreme
Court to enforce its directives
may depend precisely on such
long accumulated endowments.
This image of institutional endowments
and I will point out the danger
of institutional depletion
as legacies of the distant
past is odd however
since we also know that
institutions are continuously
being adapted even while sometimes
claiming ancient lineage.
So for example the institutions
of marriage and family
have been altered frequently
throughout American history.
It isn't just marriage
equality that is gay marriage.
Changes in laws about women's ability
to inherit property, the
shifting authority of husbands
over wives and children,
and most important perhaps
the shift in the ease and
financial consequences
of a divorce have changed not only
the practical realities
of marriage but also
the moral understandings of its purposes.
From a primarily economic partnership
meant to support the rearing of children,
to a relationship meant to provide
love and companionship
to its participants.
Thus, institutions are
inherited from the past
but there is a slight of
hand infusing older forms
with new meanings and purposes,
so why does the past matter so much
for institutions to function effectively,
and yet in another sense
the past matters so little?
This is the heart of the difficulty
of imagining and creating
good institutions.
Here I want to start
talking about what we know
from research literature
that I have pulled together
from several different places.
First, I want to talk about a recent paper
by three economists among
them Berkeley's Ted Miguel
which involved a three and a half year
Norwegian funded project
in war-torn Sierra Leone
that started to, sought to encourage more
democratic, egalitarian, participatory
and especially gender-inclusive
decision making.
The NGO that was running the big project
selected 236 villages,
this is just a huge sample
if you think about what they,
I mean the ambition of this is amazing.
And with the guidance of the researcher
they randomized those villages so that
118 villages received this intensive
training and encouragement to develop
participatory decision making
and the other 118 villages
were left to make decisions
as they always had.
Local project facilitators
stayed in the villages
working with the new more representative
decision making groups that had formed.
They monitored the groups to make sure
women were really participating.
They gave them small
grants to that they could
work together to make collective decisions
to kind of practice decision
making where it mattered.
and they actually did,
the groups successfully
made decisions together using
more participatory methods.
They built a small project once they
had succeeded in doing that
they received a larger grant and again
with lots of training and monitoring,
and participation by facilitators
who were local people
who lived in the villages and who visited
every village for one
full day a week minimum,
so this went on for three years.
All the while being
coached, trained, encouraged
and so on and so forth.
At the end of the
project the research team
assessed decision making
in all the villages.
First they ran a public goods game
and this is when each participant in an
experimental setting is given
a small amount of money.
This was the equivalent
of about two dollars
which would be enormously valuable
in any very poor African country.
And participants had a choice about
whether to put some or all of the money
in a common pot where it would be spent
for some village project or
whether to keep the money.
And they could choose how
much to put to each use.
Second the researchers,
and this is the very
clever part of this I have to say,
as they were packing up
at the end of the study
offered each village a gift to thank them
for all the participation and so forth.
Either a big box with a lot
of batteries, small batteries,
or a big box with little bags of salt
that they had measured to
be exactly equivalent in
money value to the batteries,
so there was no difference
in which was more valuable
and they left both boxes
in the village telling
villagers that they would return
at the end of the day and whichever one
the villagers didn't want
they would take back.
They also without making
explicit that this
was part of their study,
left behind a big tarp
like a big blue tarp that they had used
and they just said we
don't need this anymore
we're leaving it and
then finally they gave
every village a voucher,
another gift to thank them
for their participation and help
the voucher for the local hardware store
that could be spent however they wanted.
And they had their own people
who were still packing up
all the stuff they had
been doing in the villages
observe how decisions were made and then
their research team came
back some months later
and since they knew
every physical structure
in every village they could
judge what had happened
to that tarp, was it now forming a crucial
bit of protection, waterproofing
in the chief's thatched hut
which would be a very
reasonable and desirable
use for it from the chief's point of view,
or did it have some other use?
Okay the results of this very,
first of all just massively
ambitious project,
way beyond anything we normally
do in democracy building
and just way beyond what you
could afford to do actually,
incredibly intense, expensive project.
What were the results?
The first answer is that
there was no difference
between the experimental
and control villages.
So three and a half years of
effort made no difference.
Fostering new participatory institutions
had apparently had no effect.
But perhaps more interesting
is who did make decisions
and what decisions were made in both
the experimental and control villages?
In both sorts of villages most villagers
of the public goods game gave all
their money to the common pot.
So Sierra Leone may have been war-torn
but it was not a place in which
people did not feel obligated
and my hunch there's some other research
that would suggest pressure from the chief
is what led people to
contribute to the common pot
not selflessness, but
nonetheless the effect was
that people gave very substantial
amounts to the common pot.
When it came to choosing between
the batteries and the bags of salt
the chief chose, there
was no participation,
no gender, no nothing,
the chiefs just chose.
The tarp left behind
however did not end up
keeping the rain out of the chief's hut.
Rather when researchers
returned to the village
months later they found that in both
experimental and control villages
the tarps had been shared by village women
used to bleach their grain in the sun.
Similarly the items purchased with
the hardware store vouchers had been used
for village projects, so
perhaps the new institutions
didn't take root because chiefs,
the institution of chieftaincy
was already producing collective goods.
And we have to ask why the NGO assumed
that participatory, gender, egalitarian,
decision making would
be a vast improvement
over what these villages already had.
Now I want to talk about a second study
by sociologist Stephen Cornell
and an economist Joseph Kalt.
In a similarly ambitious project
they compared economic development
across more than 60
Native American tribes.
And I have to say this was another
just remarkably ambitious project.
They were at Harvard and they got students
from the Harvard Business School to serve
as consultants to reservation communities
that requested their help and they went
for minimum of six months,
recorded a vast battery
of economic data and offered whatever
consulting services they could offer
about managing the
tribe's economic welfare.
So this was a sort of
exchange of research data
for consulting help and of course it was
great experience for these
essentially internships
offered to these Harvard
Business School students.
All right, they found first and this is
a very, very strong finding that tribes
economic fortunes this was
the era before casinos,
so I actually don't know
how you would measure
this effectively now, but
tribes economic fortunes
differed radically depending on how well
they were governed not on
their natural resources,
local labor market conditions,
or any other advantages or disadvantages
of their objective economic situation.
Tribes that were well-governed
were economically successful.
Those that were poorly
governed failed economically
even when they had enormously rich
natural resources for example.
What then accounted for
better or worse governance?
In a stunning paper
titled, Where's the Glue?
Cornell and Kalt show
that well-governed tribes
had governance structures
that corresponded roughly
to the governance structures
Europeans recorded
at first contact with the group.
Institutions that
corresponded to long-standing
cultural patterns were most effective
at creating collective goods.
A tribe governed at first contact by
a self-perpetuating group of six shamans
that was currently
governed by a self-selected
group of Shamans who simply chose
their own successors was well-governed.
A tribe that at first contact was governed
by an elected tribal
council that was still run
council was well-governed.
But when a tribe that at first contact
was run by a single chief
who had centralized authority
was no governed by an elected
council it was poorly governed
with tribal elections frequently settled
when one faction ran another
out of office with guns.
So for reasons we don't fully understand,
institutions with
long-embedded cultural history
seem to produce better
governance than what
we might think of as the best institutions
however well they might
function in theory.
I could say much more about
Cornell and Kalt's work.
Why a shaman thought it
would be beneath his dignity
to appoint a relative
to an important post,
or how a Potawatomi group
managed its forest resources
more effectively than did the
giant lumber company warehouser.
But the bottom line is
the somewhat mysterious
but very important finding even when there
had been significant
interruptions in groups
historical patterns of governance,
so they are not saying that six shamans
governed this group and governed it
continuously from time immemorial.
In fact all these groups had enormous
interruptions in governance partly because
the US Government Bureau of Indian Affairs
imposed one common model
on all American tribes
for a period of about 40 years
and then it relented and let tribes
choose a variety of different
organizational patterns.
But also there had been
almost unimaginable
disruptions in all these
groups forms of social life.
So the federal policy
forced them to redefine
themselves as tribes
whatever their historic forms
of social organization were,
competing bands were forced to merge
in order to negotiate effectively
with the federal government,
and of course populations were decimated
by disease and slaughter,
displaced from their lands
and often subjected to cultural genocide.
Nonetheless, institutions function better
when they corresponded
to long-established,
even if interrupted, cultural models.
But must we draw the conclusion that
good institutions are
necessarily an ancient legacy
worked out over many generations and that
the heritage that makes
for good institutions
is so complex that it is almost impossible
to rebuild since we now understand
how fragile even our institutions are?
This would be a truly
frightening prospect.
So creating good institutions.
I now want to turn this argument around
by considering some of
the surprising features
of good institutions that I've observed
during my work in sub-Saharan Africa
and that other scholars have also examined
to see whether they have
lessons relevant for today.
First, I want to talk about
reinventing African chieftaincy.
Across sub-Saharan Africa
chiefs and chieftaincy
often delegitimated and in places outlawed
due to chiefs collaboration
with colonial authorities
has come roaring back with
Afrobarometer survey data
from across Africa showing
that traditional leaders
are the most trusted,
more than legislators
or government officials of all types.
Recent research from
Zambia a wonderful book
by Kate Baldwin, political scientist,
has shown that chiefs
help their communities
produce collective goods of all sorts.
Wells for clean water, roads, schools
and attracting development
projects to their villages.
Why are they able to do this and how?
One surprising answer has
to do with time horizons.
Chiefs do a fairly good
job because they have
very long time horizons, their
positions are hereditary,
not elected, and here I'll
just say as a parenthesis
that's true although at the
time of a chiefly succession
when an old chief dies the royal family
will have some negotiation and somebody
who's manifestly incompetent
might be pushed aside,
someone who is more respected,
so the royal family
itself has an investment
in the continuity of its leadership
and tries to put forward, I think,
generally more competent people.
Chiefs are also occasionally deposed
if they are truly corrupt or incompetent,
but that is usually done
by the royal family itself.
That is the chiefly lineage group,
yeah that would be called
locally the royal family.
All right, in their positions for life
chiefs see their own
well-being as identified
with that of their
communities and they have
a very long time horizon.
Contrast this with the
ever shorter time horizons
of our current institutions.
I refer not only to term
limiting our legislators
but also to the implications
of share-holder value
for corporate governance
so that corporate boards
are legally mandated
to put the performance
of a corporation's stock inevitably
a short-term indicator
above any consideration
of the long-term endowments
of the corporation,
such as loyalty and accumulated
skills of its workforce,
investment in long-term
research and development,
or long-term commitment
to a local community.
The Wells Fargo scandal isn't just about
terrible management at one gigantic bank.
But about the very short
time horizon of executives
whose astronomical bonuses are tied
to short-term performance,
sometimes only to performance
for one quarter, that's three months
in a corporation stock price.
This is mafia territory where
mergers and acquisitions
can mean taking over a
business with a large endowment
of skills, patents, land,
factories, or brand name
selling off the most valuable bits,
driving up short-term profitability
by drastically cuttings costs usually
by laying-off workers at the cost of
longer-term performance and selling out
before the market catches on
leaving the hollowed out wreckage.
This isn't just a matter
of corporate crooks
who should be prosecuted,
although my brother
used to say, only half joking,
"That such crimes made him reconsider
"his opposition to the death penalty."
Such changes are a
consequence of the broader
institutional order in
this case the redefinition
of the legal and regulatory environment
within which corporations
worked after the 1980s.
As when we redefine the ease of divorce
or the terms of our legislators,
we alter an institution
and its terms including
its taken for granted
extension forward in time.
Universities are unusual in this respect
in that many of their
members especially alumni
and many tenured faculty have lifelong
not short-term investments
in the institution,
its reputation and its future.
But the politicians who
control the university's fate
inevitably have the same short-term
pressures and incentives to
please current constituents,
admit more students, don't raise tuition,
don't raise taxes, that
make long-term investments
so difficult throughout our society.
And of course the contrast between
political institutions defined
by short-term incentives
and I should say by national boundaries
and the very long time horizon required
to combat climate change
are tragically evident.
Okay, now I want to
turn to another element
of good institutions besides time horizons
and talk about status
hierarchies and ritual forms.
I already described how institutions with
deep cultural roots function better
and are more likely to
be good in my terms.
The question is why and whether these
insights can be carried forward
to build or reinforce our
own institutional capacities?
Sociologists often discuss
an institution's legitimacy
which I recall something
like the cultural belief
that the institution is the
right kind of institution
and that it's basically good.
But it's hard to make a convincing case,
at least in my view, that people's belief
in the goodness or rightness
of their institutions
is enough to overcome the
inertia, indifference,
and selfishness, what political scientists
and others call, the free rider problem,
which can lead even say
socially committed people
to burn out when others don't pitch in.
Legitimacy is particularly
difficult to demonstrate
as an important feature
of institutional success
given that most people are quite cynical
even about institutions upon which
they depend and with which they cooperate.
That is I think a sweetness and light
institutions survive and are healthy
because everyone loves
them and believes in them
I just don't think we
have evidence that's true.
So if legitimacy isn't the main reason
why shared culture matters, why and how
does culture matter for institutions?
And here I want to talk
about another fascinating
study of villagers in rural China
that suggests one possible reason.
Lily Tsai who originally
was a graduate student
here in political science,
although I didn't know her,
studied more than 300 villages in both
poor and wealthy regions of China.
As we found for the Native American tribes
wealth did not predict whether villages
provided such collective goods
as roads, repaired paths,
elementary school classrooms,
and running water.
Whether village magistrates
were top-down appointees
or formerly democratically
elected didn't matter either.
What predicted public goods provision
was instead whether or not the village
had a traditional cultural association,
a village temple committee, or
a village wide lineage group
that both, and these are her terms,
encompassed and embedded
village officials.
That is the village officials had
to be part of such a group and that group
had to encompass most of the village.
So Tsai's argument is
that these traditional
cultural associations provided a place
where officials could receive status,
admiration, gratitude, honor,
for accomplishments that
benefited the village
and this status in turn
provided those leaders resources
with which to win cooperation
from other members
of the village community
for collective projects.
In a sense status, or what
Tsai calls, moral standing,
so you have to accomplish things that
people believe are good
provides, a reason why
chiefs, mayors, or university
deans and department chairs
may define their on well-being
by how their community
regards them and also why they may be
able to win cooperation from others.
Tsai writes quote, "Moral standing can be
"a powerful incentive.
"It not only makes people
feel good about themselves
"but also it can translate into
"economic and social advancement.
"Local officials with
higher moral standing
"may also find it easier to illicit
"citizen compliance with state policies.
"Moral standing can be
an invaluable resource
"for accomplishing a variety of
"political, social and
economic objectives."
Tsai uses a made up American analogy
to try to explain her
argument about rural China.
She says, "Imagine the
mayor of a small town
"in the United States
with only one church.
"Even if not everyone
goes to church regularly
"everyone sees the church as
"representative of the town community.
"In this kind of small town
if the mayor does something
"exemplary that benefits the town
"the minister might very
well mention his good work
"in front of the congregation
during Sunday sermon.
"This in turn can give the mayor a measure
"of moral and social
standing in addition to
"whatever he might already possess
"as a public official or a
member of the social elite.
"Increased moral standing
may also make his
"mayoral tasks easier to carry out.
"When he tries to implement
a difficult state policy
"a new requirement for
example that students
"of a different ethnic group be bused
"into the town school,
additional standing can help
"him persuade his constituents."
And she literally has in mind
minister goes up to some
leader in the town says,
"Look I hope I have you with me on this."
And if that mayor has a lot of status
people defer and say, "Oh
yeah, yeah, I'll be with you.
"You can count on me."
That's what she's talking about.
Moral standing can make citizens
more likely to trust the mayor
and defer to his judgment and can win over
particularly stubborn
opponents of the policy.
We of course are increasingly skeptical
of status inequalities.
At least since the 1960s,
and not only in the US,
survey after survey has
shown growing public distrust
of elites of all sorts,
business executives,
government officials,
physicians, and of course
the scientists whose authority we need
to affirm the reality of
human caused climate change.
Amidst rising inequality
and wealth and income
we have flattened the prestige hierarchy,
so that fewer people
command public deferences
and public trust it
comes as little surprise
that fewer are drawn to public service.
Noblesse oblige is a thing of the past,
no noblesse and no oblige.
The new status elite are perhaps those
tech billionaires who
establish foundations,
but this is a remarkably self-indulgent,
undemocratic, and in many ways strikingly
apolitical form of social commitment.
And of course the
billionaires who intervene
directly in politics like the
Koch brothers on the right,
and Buffett and Soros on the left,
are hardly greeted with
deference and gratitude.
But we should not forget that status,
moral standing, is a powerful reward.
Global institutions and
the humbler institutions
within which we live and work
would do well to remember its value
as a stored reservoir
of social commitments.
And in my own work in Africa
you can see very clearly
that chiefs have status and they receive
a lot of deference when I had to go meet
one of their various levels of chiefs,
but anyways I had to go
meet one of the big ones.
There was massive amount of attention to
everyone had to bathe carefully,
and wear pressed clothes,
and had to bring a small gift,
and there's the how,
what would we discuss.
Every aspect of this was,
there was as much concern
as Ellen Gobler has shown
in getting every element
of this lecture together
for my visit to the chief.
And then it turns out that what chiefs do
what do they actually do,
since they have no physical authority?
They don't have police.
They don't have guns.
They don't have troops.
They don't have enforcers.
They really just totally
rely on their moral authority
to make many, many, very,
very important decisions.
Well turns out that when
someone is known to be
an upstanding member of the community
they actually there's a phrase
in Chichewa that says, worth not wealth.
That person is then the
chief treats that person
in an important way if a member
of that person's family dies
the chief comes in person to give a speech
at the funeral rather
than deputing one of his
many councilors and so on and so forth.
If that person there may be
benefits to be handed out
and this person who's known to be
a good contributor to the community
might get extra one of these benefits.
But in general you can think of these
high status people like
chiefs as operating
as a kind of reservoir
of social commitment,
so that the social
commitments build up their
reservoir of influence and then they use
that influence to reward
people who in turn
build up their reservoir of influence.
It's a very recognizable pattern
and it flows through status.
Okay, then another aspect of
this and it's tied to status
has to do with the role of rituals,
and I think these traditional,
cultural practices
matter partly because they
create collectively recognized
ritual occasions and I
think we tend to be cynical
about rituals we're cosmopolitan elites.
Although I hope you will still recognize
the world I'm talking about where
there are shared rituals,
think here of an annual
PTA meeting or a church,
or in my case the ritual life
with my own academic department,
and I'll say my synagogue.
It really matters whether
we have an occasion
to celebrate the
achievements of our members,
to thank those, for example,
who served as department chair,
or others who've served
the university or who have
lived up to ideals of scholarship,
teaching or mentorship.
Indeed that is part of what
remembering Bernard Moses is about.
Such rituals serve many functions.
They build solidarity.
They allow people to
deliver the status honor,
to publicly affirm the moral standing
of those who contribute to the community.
But also very importantly
when people thank
those who have contributed
to the collective
they enhance the sense of the
value of the group itself.
And I was very aware of this, this year.
I was thinking about such things at our
big department graduation
ceremony each spring
as we celebrate the graduates,
we also celebrate our department
and the fundamental value of
our teaching and research.
We publicly thank and praise each other,
and we thus emphasize, we
create and reiterate a narrative
in which we are all
doing our share and more
to carry out our responsibility
for the institution.
We thus minimize the
awareness of free riders,
who might undermine the commitment
of everyone else to contribute.
That is we create the
illusion that we are getting
more contributions for more broader range
of our members than we
perhaps really are getting,
and we therefore minimize the visibility
of the free riders and
maximize the visibility
and the status of those who do contribute
and the extraordinary value
of the thing they contribute to.
So my department is very big on ritual,
I'm happy to say, I
think it has to do a lot
with having a lot of
female chairs, been great.
And we have had many,
many occasions where,
for example, if a
department member receives
almost any honor we have
a department reception
to honor the person and we talk about
how great that person is and we all feel,
wow I'm so lucky to be in a department
with such a terrific person and that
that person's prestige one
of our department members
was knighted by the Norwegian government
and so we felt wow we have a knight
in our department, that's fantastic.
And so we absorbed his
honor into ourselves
and we elevated our sense
of the larger purposes,
the larger shared value
of what we were doing.
And so it reinforces the idea that
there's a privilege to be part
of such a wonderful group.
Finally, collective ritual
occasions do something else
that we may normally be less aware of.
And here I'm gonna talk about a horrible,
a really horrible, image but I want you
to think about it and then
generalize it to better things.
If you think about Jim Jones and his cult
and the drinking the Kool-Aid,
that was rehearsed over and over again
as a test of who was really
committed and who wasn't.
That is there wasn't
cyanide in the Kool-Aid
until the last time, but
there was not just a way
of tricking people into
committing suicide at the end,
but it was a sign that you were committed.
Would you stand up with
everyone else and say,
"Yes, I'll drink the Kool-Aid"?
And those are ways that
leaders of all sorts,
and this is particularly true for
authoritarian societies
and for cults of all sorts,
they test who's really with them
through ritual performances.
So you want to get yourself
killed in North Korea?
Well actually it's quite easy to do,
but one of the ways to
do it is not to look
adequately enthusiastic and
attentive at some public ritual.
Literally you purge those
who cooperate in the ritual,
but the ritual allows you to
see who is really with you.
It's a sort of pre-test of that.
And so in a much more benign setting,
we can say that rituals rehearse and test
the obligations that members
of community have to one another.
You may sometimes have
wondered as you shelled out
money you can't really
afford to attend a wedding
or a Bat Mitzvah in a distant city
for relatives you hardly remember
or with whom you have
very little in common
when you do see them, why you were going
to the trouble of doing this?
But your demonstration
that you are willing
to put in that effort, spend that money,
tightens those bonds and makes them real.
So people often think
that rituals celebrate
what already exist, but
rituals actually enact
and bring into being things
that potentially exist.
I'm thinking for example
of the many weddings
and Bar and Bat Mitzvahs I've seen
where a divorced couple has to decide
how they are going to physically handle
the complexities of the ritual.
Well I turned it around
in my head and I think
that the ritual exists
partly because it is
the place where people publicly enact
and therefore reaffirm
their bonds to each other.
And they don't just reflect the bonds that
are already there, they
construct new publicly validated
definitions of those bonds.
So when I saw the parents,
the divorced parents,
of one of my nephews
walk together with him,
stand together with
him at his Bar Mitzvah,
I knew they were saying,
"We will put you first
"above our disagreements and
our distaste for each other.
"And we will be there for
you when you need us."
I don't even know that they always were,
but that declaration,
that public declaration,
shifts the ground.
It enacts and in a sense the community
then monitors those public commitments.
So ritual occasions create the moments
when people symbolize their loyalties.
When they think of the Fourth of July
for patriotic loyalties, but also again
think of the distant family who show up
for a cousin's wedding,
or an uncle's funeral.
And then find that having
reaffirmed their commitment
in this symbolic way and
this is autobiographical.
I have done this.
I both missed a very important funeral
and it permanently damaged
by relationship to a cousin,
and I have gone to things that I thought
I had no real reason to go to,
and found I was much more
committed to my family afterward.
So they've now made that commitment real
in a way it wasn't
before the ritual moment.
So rituals matter and institutions
cannot really thrive without them.
Returning to Lily Tsai's
work on Chinese villages,
we can see how village temple activity
strengthen the capacity
of village institutions
to produce collective goods.
She writes, "Villagers
have clear obligations
"to contribute to and participate in
"village temple activities,
"because these collective
activities represent
"group tributes to the
village's guardian deities.
"Village residents are
expected to make donations
"to help fund these activities.
"The names of donors and
the amount they donated
"are posted publicly on the temple wall.
"Village temples are an important symbol
"of the village community.
"They provide strong
institutions enforcing
"each member's
responsibility to contribute
"to the collective good
and numerous opportunities
"for publicizing whether members
"have fulfilled their responsibilities."
Rituals really matter, I'm back to me,
and without shared rituals
the emotional charge
they generate and the
concentrated social information
they convey it is difficult
to construct binding social ties.
Enduring social institutions necessarily
have a symbolic core one that conveys
membership and meaning, not
just practical interests
and enforceable obligations.
Often that symbolic core and the rituals
that reinforce it work at
an emotional and unconscious
rather than purely rational level.
This I think accounts
for some of the emotional
reactions to the recent election.
Where love of country has been expressed
in symbolic rituals, like the arms linked
around Lake Merritt in Oakland.
Only because we hold America
and its traditions sacred
do we feel so violated when
those values are threatened.
So status and ritual go together
and reinforce each other
and both reinforce the
ability of institutions
to call forth commitments
from their members.
Now I want to return and
this is my last point,
big point, I have a couple
of other small points,
to the practical issues
who gains and loses?
Most of literature on
creating institutions
really is based on a model
of complex negotiations,
that is you form
institutions when you realize
it's in your interests
and you sort of agree
to bind yourself over to a
set of institutional processes
and those, and then if you
read Acemoglu and Robinson
and such literature
they have more an image
that it's when you're truly threatened
with losing your control
then you make concessions
that essentially broaden and deepen
participation things like that.
And then why those things
last they're not so clear on.
But I would say that the models of where
those institutional commitments
come from are very thin.
They say a lot of powerful
things about interests
and very little about the other aspects
that go along with interests.
But if we turn to interests for a minute,
I think it's true that
institutions cannot survive
if over the long haul
people see that the ideals
or justifications the institutions embody
bear no relationship to the ways they
allocate rewards and
punishments or sanctions.
Although paradoxically
and here I think we really
have to take this into account,
institutions survive
very well and can survive
over a very long period of time even if
most people who play by their rules never
realize the benefits they promise.
That I think is in fact routine.
Many, many people try to become academics
and most will never become the
fancy professors we're privileged to be.
Think of the opportunity
the market promises
for ability and hard
work, in a world in which
most people will, most not everyone,
but most people will
get some kind of a job
and will have some way
of supporting theirself
but most people will not achieve
most of the rewards the
system seems to promise.
People know that the
American Dream probably
won't work for them, but
they continue to be attached
to the institutions that
support that fantasy.
Or the continuing allure of marriage
even for those who never marry,
or who are in situations where marriage
is not a practical possibility,
even as actual marriages fail many people.
So institutions do not have to actually
reward everyone who plays by their rules.
And I don't think they do,
I don't think we have evidence that
that's what makes them work.
But even though institutions can keep hold
of imaginations even of many people
whom they let down in the end,
that is very different from it becoming
evident that the very
standards at the core
of the institution's
narrative do not work.
That even those who are
successful in the institutions
own terms aren't rewarded, and here I want
to briefly mention a great
book, it's an old book,
by Harrison and Cynthia White,
on institutional transformation in the
French painting world and they essentially
are trying to explain the
rise of the impressionists.
What they show is that the academic system
for regulating French painting
which was a very well-established
institutional system
with its own educational system and then
its channels of mobility and so forth,
depended on the notion that artists
would achieve rewards and the reward
was usually patronage
from the French state
that would then commission
the successful people
to paint something for a public building,
or to create a public sculpture,
or something like that.
Those winners in that
system would be chosen
in these enormous juried shows,
and as thousands of provincials started
to long to become artists and therefore
flooded into Paris trying to succeed
spending years creating one painting
on which their whole fate depended.
Those thousands and thousands of paintings
and if you've ever been to the Renwick
you can kind of imagine
what this was like,
these very, very tall ceilings,
very high ceilings, and walls covered
with thousands of paintings.
Then you had these juries,
let's imagine six or seven men
in some kind of black
robes wandering around
they couldn't even see the paintings.
They couldn't even see them.
There could be no pretense
that they were choosing
the best, that they truly were judging
which artist deserved
these enormous rewards.
So it wasn't just that
the number of rewards
was far too small for
the number of aspirants,
it was that the pretense
that the rewards made sense
in terms of the
institution's own narrative
couldn't be maintained.
And then I don't know how true this is
but the Whites paint this picture where
a new institutional
system grows up outside
the old order they call it the
dealer or critic system and that's the one
out of which the support
for the impressionists
emerges but also a new narrative which is
the starving artist in the garret who is
discovered by the early purchasers who see
the genius and the artist starves and dies
but those who supported his
or her work are vindicated.
Okay, so it may seem
surprising that narratives,
stories linking more meanings to outcomes,
could be essential to the
patterned realities we call institutions,
but I think they are incredibly important.
When we try to export
participatory decision making
institutions to Africa,
or we aspire to create
new global institutions to
regulate carbon emissions,
or to prevent war, or to rescue refugees,
we may not think that we are constructing
a persuasive narrative.
A narrative for example
about how empowered women
will be able to prevent
themselves from acquiring HIV.
But that is precisely what
drives policy formation.
Policy comes when the narrative
is moving and persuasive
and seems to makes sense.
So narratives are really
central to creating institutions
even as we try to envision
rules that will guide
expectations over the long run and somehow
we home acquire enduring authority
to regulate or constrain action.
Indeed I think good research suggests
that creating new
institutions usually means
in fact not creating
institutions from scratch.
It usually means adapting
pieces of already existing
institutions and I think narratives play
a critical role in this process.
I think that's why in the
Cornell and Kalt findings
it matters what Native American groups
governance structures
were a long time ago,
even when there isn't continuity
in the actual concrete institution.
And I want to use just
a couple of last pieces
of research to suggest
that this might be true
without having done research that can show
that it actually is true.
And one is a book on Africa
by an anthropologist,
Sandra Barnes, the book is
called Patrons and Power.
It's a wonderful study of what happened
in a suburb of Lagos, Nigeria
when enormous numbers of people, millions,
had moved into an unincorporated
area outside Lagos.
So they had no political representation
and no way to get services like
running water, and
sanitation, and so forth.
What did they do?
And these were groups from
multiple different ethnic groups.
They weren't even all Yoruba,
let alone from the same Yoruba tribe.
They created chiefs.
They invented chieftaincies.
And then people who wanted to be chiefs,
invented genealogies that legitimated
their chieftaincy claims and so
what's fascinating is these weren't
actual chiefs who set up shop there.
This was a collective attempt to create
legitimate forms of political authority,
and political access by
taking the familiar narrative
that everyone could recognize about
how you form yourself as a collectivity
and what it means to be
represented politically
and then inventing brand new chieftaincies
which in fact got them represent,
I mean that was then those
people had a lot of influence.
They could go to politicians.
There's a very similar story from
a totally different historical era
which is from a book that's much
too complicated to summarize,
but Rick Biernacki's book
the Fabrication of Labor.
And Biernacki argues that if
you try to look at how labor,
that is the relationship between
factory owners and workers,
got constituted differently
in Britain and Germany
what you need to see is what the earlier
institutions were that they
adapted at great remove
in order to imagine what the factory was
and what labor was.
And Biernacki says that
they were essentially
in Germany where they did not already have
a market in labor and in commodities
at the time of industrialization,
they adapted the futile form
these would have been the Junkers
who could get corvee
labor from their peasants.
That's one day a month
you have to come and build
the stone wall around my
land or something like that.
And they saw when they paid for labor,
they thought of it in that way
they were buying the time of the laborer
with a wad of money.
When the British constructed factories
they already had a market
in labor and commodities
so what they thought they were doing
is something like the putting-out system
brought within four walls.
They were buying the piece of cloth
and paying for it in terms of
how high quality the cloth was,
how many threads per inch there were,
and Germans and British factory owners
continued to use radically
different systems
for understanding how
they paid their workers.
Based on the institutional
models, the imaginaries,
they were drawing on in these
two very different contexts.
So, now I conclude and
my conclusion is really
that the question of how you create
good institutions is so critical
that we really need
serious research on this
so that the next time
we have to think about
such problems we don't find that our
theoretical and research cupboard is bare.
That is the a-number-one,
this is not a problem
I'm gonna solve, this is a problem
I think is urgently important.
But I have a couple of
final morals of the story.
The first is don't flee
from effective institutions, seek them.
Don't let yourself be, I
don't know what word to use,
diluted, overwhelmed, sucked in,
by the American romance in which
this is very American
if we can only throw off
institutions and just
be free to be ourselves.
The day after the
election I was talking to,
I bought shoes believe it or not.
I mean I was so crazed, but anyway,
I was talking to this young woman
from Zappos and she said that,
oh she was very chatty.
She said, oh yes, I
live in Nevada and this
you know terrible outcome
election blah, blah, blah.
And then she said, I didn't vote,
in Nevada you can vote none
of the above, she said.
And that's how I voted because I wanted
to be true to my conscience.
I, well yeah, I'll leave that hanging.
And I also want to say
that one more thing,
which is loss of an institutional legacy
also constricts our imagination about
what politics and social
life are or could be.
That is it's not only that
we base our institutions
on narratives that seem persuasive,
but that the narratives we constitute
about who we are and about our own lives
in turn depend on institutional models.
So just as institutional
capacities often come
from resuscitating older
institutional models
to serve in new ways, as we saw with the
suburb of Lagos or the
workers and bosses in Germany.
The loss of institutions
threatens to leave us
with the understanding that
only market institutions
money, raw coercive power,
and market forces are real.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] I have two
issues slash questions
I'd like to raise, one
is coming back to your
definition of good and good institutions,
and good I mean we may know
what is good versus evil,
but good can have many definitions.
And an example is, one
example is the election.
And there are you talked
about people gathering
around Lake Merritt, well there are people
you know this was a
very tiny, tiny majority
not the popular vote but the
electoral college vote was tiny.
And there are people who
felt that voting for Trump
was good and that that
government will be good.
So I think we need to recognize good.
I was watching television the other night
and a potential secretary of
I guess the interior said,
climate change, saying that climate change
is caused by man is silly.
We don't agree, I assume
nobody in this room agrees, but
that is one definition
of a good institution.
So I think we need to, I
mean, that is one person
perhaps a group's definition of good.
So good institutions can differ.
May other question comment
is a lot of your work
has been about NGOs and criticizing NGOs
and you didn't mention that here but
NGOs, there are lots of NGOs,
but that is an institution that, and
I don't know do you want to
say something about NGOs?
(Ann laughs)
- Yeah let me try to address
this thing about good.
So I was, one reason I
define good institutions
really by the set of outcomes which is
that they produce I don't
know what you'd call
but let's call them public
goods in the economist sense,
rather than all the other
things I might think
make institutions good
like being inclusive,
and democratic, and participatory,
or being just by my lights,
or being representing my ethnic group,
or representing God's
will or this and that.
I mean I agree with you that when it comes
to people's moral
understandings of what's good,
I don't think actually we face chaos.
It might feel like it I actually
don't think that's
true, but it's true that
people can have profoundly
different starting points
for thinking about such
issues and they can end up,
I think looking at (mumbles) here
but they can end up so profoundly divided
in certain ways that the whole
set of premises they have
about what their common life should be
really create divisions they can't bridge.
So I'm not saying that
there's only one definition
of the good and that I
have it or something,
I really was trying to use
a very sort of concrete
and pragmatic definition
of good institutions,
not as the ones that we
would necessarily find
morally the most appealing,
but the ones that are
able to accomplish certain
kinds of things in their
particular historical context.
And I think they often don't look like
the kind of institutions
I mean you would not like
living in a chieftaincy I
can absolutely guarantee it.
You would hate it, no you would hate it.
And many, many people go
to Africa, for example,
and just see these
things as totally corrupt
which to some degree they are,
that is you give a gift to the chief
and if some goodies come into the village
the chief will certainly
take, skim a share.
But not nearly the share that the
government officials will skim (laughs).
And there are reasons for that, so.
- [Man] Hi my name's Ethan.
I'm a sociologist at UC Davis.
You mentioned this piece about status,
hierarchies and rituals
and gave some examples
and I'm trying to struggle with this
how we've divided ourselves and like
the identity politics that seem to be
really driving a lot of things, and so.
But the examples you gave
of where hierarchies work,
or where status works, rituals
work, seemed very small.
And so I'm asking you if you've thought
have we just outgrown
our capacity to reach
across demographics to
share in that type of work?
And that that's a place for change?
Or is it that we are dividing ourselves
into smaller identities
that is problematic?
- Yeah, I was going to say oh shoot
that's a really good point and I hoped
wouldn't be too obvious.
No, I think you're right that the image
of ritual that I find very persuasive
is the kind of thing that happens
in face-to-face situations or at least
in televisable moments of situations
and that it's a little hard to figure out
exactly how that applies to whole,
very large, collectivities.
But I think you're still
pointing to something
which is that, that if
what our current politics
and the desire for let's call it
let's use the Charles Taylor
or whatever term recognition.
So enormous numbers of groups
with different identities
and different needs and it's not just
racial and ethnic identity politics
or sexual community identity politics.
Really it's part of, or religious
group identity politics,
it's part of I think the
whole way we've learned
to speak about collective life
is to make sure everyone feels recognized.
And then the question is does that allow
room for there to be
a recognition of some kind of elite,
and here I'll just use the
brutal term elite status,
that everyone would be willing to defer to
because we see those people?
And I'm really not thinking of me.
But I'm thinking of people like people who
would serve on some
governmental commission
to try to deal with the crisis facing us
if money for Medicare runs out.
Or people who would be seen
as potential neutral arbiters
and I think if our theory
is that everyone has
his or her own reality,
that your reality is shaped
by your social position so that
standpoint theory is our only theory,
I think we're really in bad shape.
I think those are not good bases on which
to build collective institutional life.
So in a way I agree with
you but I think that
if you really want to think about
how to rebuild institutions
confronting the fact
that and even coming out of this election
everyone is gonna conclude
that the problem is
that the elites are too elitist.
Well my problem is the
elites aren't elite enough.
What's the matter with them?
You know, enriching yourself privately
is totally incompatible with really
being a member of the elite.
If you want to claim
national leadership status
you have to be in some ways heroic,
and maybe this gets a little to
Joanna's question about the NGOs.
I think one of the
reasons that people have
run headlong in, sometimes
in not very fruitful
direction is because they're
looking for some kind of
heroic self-abnegation, self-sacrifice,
so we're much more
willing to believe that,
now his name is gonna go
completely out of my head,
but the partners in health guy.
- [Man] Farmer.
- Yes, thank you, James Farmer.
- [Audience Members] Paul.
- Paul, Paul Farmer, sorry.
James Farmer is someone
else important, but not,
yeah Paul Farmer has a kind of heroism
I kind of genuine elite status.
A kind of genuine willingness to sacrifice
for the public good that allows sort of
the collective imagination to focus on him
and the vision he's offering.
And I think we don't know
how to construct that again.
I mean it's even if you
think about Skopcol's book,
Protecting Soldiers and Mothers,
one of the reasons women
during the Progressive Era
were able to be so influential
in American politics
is because Americans
don't like politicians
they think they're corrupt
and self-interested,
and women were seen as above politics
because they didn't have the vote.
Because what they did
was seen as really being
for the public good so they could mobilize
some kind of prestigious
commissions and things,
that's exactly what they did do.
You know to study the
problem of tainted milk,
or the problem of infants dying,
or the problem of rat feces in the meat,
or whatever it was, and try to get reform.
So I think realizing that we've gotten
so good at being suspicious of elites,
that I think it's actually undermined
our ability to think about
what we need going forward, so.
Yes.
- [Woman] Thank you I'm a little thrown
by the great questions ahead of me.
You said something that I understood
to be seek effective institutions.
Can you say a little more about that?
- Well I think partly that was the whole
talk was meant to be about that.
But just I guess I have this fear
that people are going to
turn away from government.
Going to say, "Oh I hate bureaucracy.
"I hate the administration."
For instance if you're a member of the
university community, which I can't help
but think about because it's the community
I'm most attached to and really there's
a kind of let's get
rid of this chancellor.
And then, oh we don't like him either,
let's get rid of the next one,
then oh let's get, oh it
may be that some of them
have been much better than others.
But the idea that sort of slash and burn
is really the way to go in terms of
our institutional life, I
just don't think it's true.
And so I'm not justifying any particular
person who was either
incompetent, or self-dealing,
or corrupt, or didn't tell the truth.
But I think the level of sort of savagery
that we think is now appropriate
toward anyone who attempts to take
a position of leadership
if that's our style
then don't we really expect
leaders to be demagogues
who can just ride rough shot over that,
because any reasonable person
how could he or she stand up to it, so?
That's my, that's where I was coming from.
- [Woman] Thank you that
clarifies, thank you.
- [Woman] Talk about
what the difference is
between your idea of endowment
and the idea of legitimacy that is used
to evaluate the extent to which people
respond to the purposes
that you talked about
and the principles that are embedded
in the purposes of the
different institutions.
It seems to me that's
what legitimacy is about
is an evaluation that's
continual and perpetual
that people are constantly doing about
every institution that
affects their lives.
And that it's a lot different than just
an endowment of something.
- Well, okay so for me the word endowment
is meant to connote I guess all the
long legacy of other people's efforts
that have built something
up to be what it is.
And actually again I'll
refer to the university here
where it's incredible
privilege to be here.
The University of California Berkeley
is certainly the greatest
public university
in the world and maybe the greatest
single university in the world.
It's not because of anything I did.
It's because of
generations and generations
of people, taxpayers who
put their tax dollars
into the institutions,
administrators who built it,
indeed the endowment of the
corpus of scholarly work
that comes from generations
and generations before us
and you know this very well.
And so I have a feeling
that that endowment
gets built up over time,
sometimes it also involves
an endowment of money and you're right
it involves an endowment of
purposes that's for sure.
And I don't want to fight you,
especially you to the death about
rejecting the concept of legitimacy.
But there my sense is, wow we would could
dissipate this thing pretty
quickly, for example,
if just let me do a really
worst case scenario.
Berkeley desperately needs money.
It decides a Berkeley degree
because of the brand
is really worth a lot,
and so it will just sell them.
Something very similar by the way happened
before the French Revolution
when the French state
was desperate to raise
money and it sold offices.
And actually the English Crown did it
before the English Revolution also.
They sold baronets.
You know it's not impossible
if you're desperate enough
and you just would sell
degrees or sell them
for some minimal amount of symbolic effort
knowing full well they didn't
really represent anything
and then you would
spend up that endowment,
you would deplete it almost overnight.
So that's the sense in
which I think of endowment
as that sort of accumulated set
of commitments and resources
and so I guess that's how I mean it.
Now, I agree with you.
The reason I don't like
the term legitimacy
or at least it's the fallback when people
try to explain why culture
matters for institutions.
The thing they grab first
is the word legitimacy
and they tend to mean by it,
a belief that the
institution is right or good
or the way to do things
and there certainly is
that's gonna make a difference.
For example, if at some
point the Supreme Court
tells Donald Trump that
he has to do something
and he refuses you can
kind of imagine Americans
rising up or and saying,
wait a minute our system
is that the Supreme Court
is the ultimate arbiter
of national law and people have accepted
that for generations and we
regard it as illegitimate
for you to violate a
Supreme Court directive.
And that would be classic.
But I guess I think that
those sorts of beliefs
that some institution
is really right or good,
or that the people currently running it
are right or good, that
often really doesn't exist.
And again with my, when I, hanging out
in sub-Saharan Africa
and I'd say to people,
oh you know what do you
think of your chief?
And oh pew, they didn't use that term.
But they'd say, oh you know he just comes
he comes to every funeral.
Chiefs can't eat at a funeral because
it has to do with witchcraft beliefs,
anyway they don't eat food.
But he said that he
comes and he doesn't eat,
but he brings his 10
councilors and they eat
you out of house and
home and this very vital
thing for people who are very, very poor.
And then, so I said to this guy,
so well then why don't you
just refuse to obey him?
He just looked at me as
if I was out of my mind.
He looked at me as
literally I mean I think
he couldn't believe I said such a thing,
and the reason was he said,
but what if, what if, and he
could hardly get the words out,
what if someone died?
And what he was saying is that
you couldn't bury your dead.
You couldn't bury your
dead without this guy.
So even if he himself is a bad chief
chieftaincy it's what makes the world run.
I guess if you will accept
that legitimacy doesn't mean
thinking chieftaincy is good,
it means thinking that chieftaincy
is actually how the world runs.
- [Woman] Please join me in thanking Ann.
(audience applauds)
(pleasant music)